اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد نواصل تغطيه
للقتال العنيش في السودان اشتباكات عنيفه
في محيط مطار الخرطوم والقياده العامه
وتبادل اتهامات بين الجيش والدعم السريع
بخرق الهدنه في بيان اتهمت قوات الدعم
السريع الجيش بكسر الهدنه المعلنه
والاستمرار في شن هجمات وقالت ان الجيش
يحرك قوات عسكريه ومجموعات مسلحه من مختلف
المدن الى الخرطوم الدعم السريع حمل الجيش
المسؤوليه شن هجمات باسلحه ثقيله على
مواقعه ما تسبب في مقتل مدنينا واتهمت
الجيش ايضا بمواصله عمليات قصف تجمعات
سكنيه بالطائرات وتدمير مستشفيات
[موسيقى]
العامه
هذا حقنا الان الى القياده العامه
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مع سمرار الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع التي تدخل يومها الخامس في
السودان افادت بريسكا قبل قليل بارتفاع
عدد قتل المواجهات في السودان الى 270 على
الاقل من جانبها قالت نقابه اطباء السودان
بان عدد الضحايا المدنيين ارتفع الى 174
قتيلا على الاقل واشارت الى تسجيل 20141
حاله اصابه بين المدنيين والتي يقابلها
نقص فادح في الرعايه الطبيه بسبب تعرض بعض
المستشفيات للاخلاء القصري وذكرت نقابه
اطباء السودان بان نحو 30 مدنيا قتلوا في
اشتباكات امس رغم الاعلان عنهن
هذا واندلعت حرائق هائله في محيط مبنى
القياده العامه للجيش ومطار الخرطوم صباح
اليوم جراء الاشتراكات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع هذا وتحدث شهود عيان
عن استهداف خزانات وقود داخل المطار الذي
اختصاعد منه الادخين الكثيفه حيث تستمر
الاشتباكات بين الطرفين في السودان منذ
خمسه ايام رغم موافقه قوه الدعم السريع
على مقترح وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بعقله
لوقف اطلاق النار لمده 24 ساعه
اظهرت مقاطع مصوره نشرتها مواقع التواصل
اثار قصف طال مجمع الرواد السكني في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم صباح اليوم في
ظل الاقتتال العنيف الذي يدور بين قوات
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع منذ السبت
الماضي
مشاهدينا من الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك السالم واخر
ما لديك من معلومات حول تطورات الجاريه في
البلاد
هذه باخر التصريحات التي وردت وهي البيان
الذي كان عن الجيش الذي قال فيه الجيش
السوداني الذي تصدى
العدو وخسائر كبيره من الارواح العديد من
العربات القتاليه هذا الامر جاء بعد
اشتباكات عنيفه العاصمه الخرطوم
صباح اليوم
هذه اللحظات
الاشتباكات كانت في مناطق متفرقه من ولايه
الخرطوم ثم بعد ذلك جاءت هذه الاجتماع
متفرقه في نقاط كثيره جدا
احدثت معرا كبيرا لدى المواطنين
واثارت لديهم كذلك الخوف مما جعل الشوارع
الخرطوم خاليه تماما من الماره ولا توجد
اي حركه هناك ايضا موضوع الوضع الانساني
كذلك الحديث فيما يتعلق بالمستشفيات التي
خرجت عن الخدمه
والمجهودات التي تم في ذلك لكن مع احمد في
ظل هذه الاخبار السلبيه ان لدينا خبرا
ايجابيا
حقيقه لنا زمن طويل من الاستماع الى
الاخبار الجيده في ظل هذه الظروف الصعبه
لكن من الاخبار الجميله ان محطه بالمياه
بدات وتم تشغيلها الان بثلاثه طرمبات
والشكر مياه بلاد الخرطوم والتي هي باسيام
الصيانه كانت مجتهده لاعاده المياه الى
المواطنين الان بدات في العمل
سيبدا العمل في محطه بحري لكن ما زال يعني
العمال يبحثون عن القياده
مره اخرى لمتابعه الحديد حول الخدمات لكن
اسمحلي فقط بالتنويه هذه الصور التي نشرها
الجيش السوداني وهي عباره عن مقطع مصور
لاصطفاف قوات الجيش السوداني قبل ما يسميه
بالمرحله الثانيه للعمليه العسكريه اذا
معكم مشاهدينا في متابعه هذه الصور التي
نشرها الجيش السوداني
الاصطفاف قواته قبل بدء المرحله الثانيه
للعمليه العسكريه مشاهدينا كل ذلك طبعا في
سياق الاشتباكات بين الطرفين المستمر
لليوم الخامس رغم موافقه قوات الدعم
السريع على مقترح وزير الخارجي
لوقف اطلاق النار لمده 24 ساعه امازلنا
معكم مشاهدينا ايضا في متابعه هذه الصور
لعربات الدفع الرباعي واصطفاف هذه القوات
التابعه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه او
الجيش السوداني قبل بدء المرحله الثانيه
للعمليه العسكريه
مشاهدينا من الخرطوم ينضم الينا السيد مكي
المغربي الكاتب الصحفي
وبدايه هل كان اندلاع هذه المواجهات
متوقعه بنسبه اليك ام مفاجئا عطفا على ما
سبقها ايضا من احداث سياسيه وحرب كلاميه
بين الطرفين
الحرب الدائره الان التي يمكن نسميها
بمعركه الخرطوم
هي ليست متوقعه فقط من خلال نقاشنا مع
خبراء عسكريين منذ فتره طويله وبعضهم من
هو بالمعاش وخارج حتى دائره الاحداث
والسياسه يسمونها
المواجهه المؤجله وهذه الكلمه انا سمعتها
قبل عامين
وترددت في العسكريه كثيره
فالاشكاليه انه
بالحسابات العسكريه الداخليه انها كانت
ستحدث
ولكن بالحسابات السياسيه كان هنالك تحويل
على الحوار وتعويل على
تاجيل موضوع الدمج
ومقترحات على شاكل يتم الدم على بعد عشر
سنوات
وحديث باعتبار انه ما يحدث هو مجرد سوء
تفاهم بين البرهان
وغيرهم
واشاعات على شاكله ان هنالك الفلول يضربون
النار وكذا لكن بالنسبه للخبراء العسكريين
هذا كان كله حديث لا محله من الاعراب هما
كانوا يرون ان الجيش القومي السوداني الذي
اسس في العام 1925 في قوه الدفاع السودان
وشارك في الحرب العالميه الثانيه وهو
موجود ككيان قومي لن يقبل باي حال من
الاحوال وجود قوات الدعم السريع بهذا
الشكل المستقل نعم
وهذا ما كان يمكن ان تضمنه العم ليه
السياسيه استاذ مكي بالتاكيد لكن وفق هذه
المعطيات التي اشرت اليها يعني هل يمكن
القول انه قد ان هذه المواجهات ربما دقت
المسمار الاخير في نعش العمليه السياسيه
في السودان والتي كانت كما تابعت معنا
ويتابع الجميع ان كانت قاب قوسين او ادنى
من التوقيع لاتفاق النهائي
لم تكن قاب قوسين او ادنى الا من باب
التطمين
والا من باب ما يعتبره العسكريون انه
تخدير
لهم لتمرير مخطط
تاجيل الدمج لعشر سنوات الذي كان يتبناه
الدعم السريع
ولم تكن العمليه السياسيه بشكلها الموجود
تضمن هذا
الدمج لانها لم تكن عمليه سياسيه وطنيه
خالصه
كان هنالك صراع محاور
مطفي السودان
وهنالك رغبه من بعض
الدول لممالئه الطرف على طرف
ولذلك انا اعتقد ان الاشكاليه في العمليه
السياسيه انا لا اصل الى درجه
حديث من ناوي الذي يعتبر انه اتفاق الاطار
هو سبب الحرب ولكن اعتقد التصلب الذي
مارسه بعض الاطراف في الاتفاق الاطار
المجلس المركزي الذين يصرون على ان يعينوا
هم رئيس الوزراء مع اقصاء كل الاخرين لا
حق لهم في تعيين رئيس الوزراء بما في ذلك
حركات مسلحه مثل موقعه على اتفاقيه
جبال السلام كلهم محظورون تماما من من ان
يكون لديهم حق حتى في مقترحات من هو رئيس
الوزراء وبعضهم يقول سنعين رئيس الوزراء
وبعد عامين يمكنكم ان تتدخلوا وتجعلوا
فتره انتقاليه اخرى بمعنى
على شاكله فتره انتقاليه مركبه وعلى مراحل
وهم يعملون بمهل وانا اعتقد انهم
هي السليمه تج
اه السوداني
وخدروا انفسهم بالحديث انه من يعطل
العمليه السياسيه فلول وانه من لم يقبلها
على علاجها او كما جاء في المثل العربي
بعجرها وبجرها يعتبر هو عدو للثوره وغير
ذلك من من قاموس
التصنيفات السياسيه في حين انه
البرهان الى حد كبير كان يضحي
بوجوده داخل الجيش يعني او البرهان وضع
وجوده داخل الجيش في مرمى الخطر لفتره لكي
نعم بمعنى انه كان يفاضل على اشياء يعتقد
العسكريون انه لا تفاوض عليها
مثل موضوع الدمج
ان ياتي المدنيون والسياسيون
والدعم السريع نفسه
ويسمع مقترحات حتى من دول انه هذا فرع من
الجيش متى يندمج وكيف يندمج واللجنه هل
تكون عسكريه ان تكون مشتركه ان تاتي الامم
المتحده هذا الكلام بالنسبه لنا نحن في
فضاء الاعلام والسياسه نعتبره كلام ونقاش
العمل ونتحدث فيها ولكنه كان يشكل درجه
عاليه جدا من درجات الاحتقان ولذلك انا
اقول انه ما حدث الان هو ليس
بسبب الاتفاق الاطاري انا لا اتفق مع من
يقول ان الاتفاق الايطالي والعمليه
السياسيه
طيب وضحت هذه النقطه لكن يعني رغم هذا
التراكم وكل ما تفضلت به يعني لماذا لم
تفلح حاليا اي جهود في نزعفتيل هذه الازمه
رغم دخول دول وازنه في في في خط هذه
الازمه نتحدث عن الولايات المتحده نتحدث
عن دول اقليميه هل الازمه تكمل في عدم
توحيد هذه الجهود في واحده في تقديرك
هذه جهود شكليه ما حقيقيه ليس حقيقه ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تتعامل مع
الصراع باعتبار انه طرفين وانها تعدل بين
الطرفين وانها ترى الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع كذا هذا كلام يمكن ان يقال على
مستوى وزير الخارجيه الذي يحتاج لديه
شواغر في تقاريره التي
بمؤكدعى الى الكونغرس وتعقد جلسه هيلينج
سماع ويكون يجب عليه ان يقول انه اتصل
بحميته واتصل بالبرهان
وعرض عليهم البدنه وقام بذلك من اجل
المدنيين والحقوه الانسانيه فنحن نعرف ما
يحدث على المستوى الدبلوماسي الامريكي
والسياسي لكن المنظومه الامنيه والمجتمع
الاستخباري الامريكي مع الجيش السوداني
ومع الامن السوداني وهذا وضح تماما في
جوله مدير المخابرات الامريكيه الى
القاهره ثم زياره مدير المخابرات
السودانيه
الى واشنطن ووضح تماما باختصار عندما يكون
المعادله امنيه
فان حليفه الامريكا الاولى في المنطقه هي
مصر
عندما يكون الموضوع اقتصادي واستثمارات
والاوبك واسعار النفط فان الحلفاء تكون هي
السعوديه والامارات وغيرها لانها لديها
الثقل الاقتصادي الدولي لكن مساله ان ان
تحمل تصريحات السيد وزير الخارجيه والهدنه
التي عرضها على محمل الجد وانها ضغوط هذا
الكلام كيف يمكن التصور اذا موقف الجيش
موقف الولايات المتحده اذا ما يحدث الان
اذا كان الموقف المصرح به ليس مقنع
بالنسبه لك يعني ما الذي يدل اذا خلف
الكواليس
الى المشاعر الامني والموقف المصري فقط
هي الولاده المتحده الامريكيه دائما تقوم
سياستها الخارجيه على سياسه الاحتواء
المزدوج
والسيناريوهات المفتوحه
والتعامل مع كل الاطراف لكن عندما يحدث
خلاف فان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تفضل
الامن على العمليه السياسيه
الاولويه الامنيه بالنسبه
ما هي اهميه السودان بالولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
دعك من الكلام الكثير والعلاقات التاريخيه
وكذا والصداقه لا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه السودان مهم اليها في امرين لا
ثالث لهما الامر الاول ضمان ان السودان لا
يتحول الى ماوى لارهاابهين وان يكون
السودان شريك في مكافحه الارهاب الموجود
في المنطقه حرام في نيجيريا والشباب
الصومالي وغير ذلك وجماعات القاعده وغير
ذلك
وهذا هذا هو هذه الاهميه الاولى الاهميه
الثانيه للسودان ان يبقى السودان بعيد من
روسيا طيب من هو الذي ما هو الجهه الضامنه
في السودان لابتعاد السودان من المسار
الارهابي
وان يكون هناك
هي الجيش والامن تحديدا واصلا يوجد تعاون
على مكافحه الارهاق منذ ان كان السودان في
قائمه الارهاب التعاون في مكافحه الارهاب
بدا في عام فمن كانت السفاره الامريكيه في
الخرطوم مغلقه
وافتتحت في العام 2002 واستمر التعاون
الامني في مكافحه الارهاب
وبالرغم من وجود السودان في قائمه الارهاب
لكن تقارير الثانويه للخارجيه نفهم ذلك ان
الموقف الولايات المتحده قد لا يلتزم
بمبدا الحياد طويلا
بين الطرفين وربما نستمع او نتابع مواقف
ضد ضد الدعم السريع
الاهميه الثانيه لامريكا وهي القشه التي
ضامت قسم الزهره البعير
الاهميه الثانيه بالنسبه للسودان بالنسبه
لامريكا في السودان ان يبقى السودان بعيد
من الروسي
تحديدا روسيا والصين لكن لا يتعاملون مع
موضوع الصين بذات الحساسيه التي يتعاملون
بها مع وضوح روسيا
للاسف والاسبوع حظ الدعم السريع ان حميتك
موجود قبل يوم من اعلان الحرب على
اوكرانيا
من قبل روسيا كان موجود في موسكو
والتقارير الامريكيه نفسها والتي وصلت الى
احد ان تكون تقارير مودعه
سيد مكي
طيب يبدو ان نفقه الاتصال اذا مع ضيف
الخرطوم الاستاذ الكاتب الصحفي مكي
المغربي
مشاهدينا في الجهود الاقليميه للتهدئه
تلقى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان اتصالا من نظيره الامريكي تركز
على الوضع في السودان واكد الامير فيصل بن
فرحان اوبنكن خلال الاتصال على اهميه وقف
التصعيد العسكري في السودان وضروره حمايه
المدنيين والاجانب كما شددا على اهميه امن
واستقار السودان وشعبه قبل ذلك وفيرات
السياق اكد وزير الخارجيه سامح شكري اكد
ان بلاده ستكثف الاتصالات مع الاطراف
السودانيه المتنازعه من اجل استئناف
الحوار السلمي لتسويه الوضع بينهما
وجدد شكري التاكيد على ضروره امتناع جميع
اصحاب المصلحه والنفوذ الاجانب عن تصعيد
الوضع في السودان معبرا عن عمله في التوصل
الى حل قريب بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
ونعيد مشاهدينا التفكير بما كشفته مصادر
خاصه العربيه عن تحركات مصريه اقليميه
تشمل دخول مراقبين دوليين للوصول الى وقف
اطلاق النار خلال عيد الفطر
وفتح ممرات امنه بين مصر والسودان لمده 48
ساعه للسماح بالنقل المصابين ودخول
المساعدات الانسانيه بالاضافه الى تخصيص
لجنه امميه دوليه وتسهيل دخولها للاشراف
على كافه الاسرى من الجانبين وتسهيل مهام
بعلاج الامم المتحده وبرامج الغذاء
العالمي من خلال تعيين قوه خاصه لتامين
مهامهم داخل الارض السودانيه
وكشفت المصادر ايضا وجود مشاورات حول
تشكيل لجنه دوليه محايده مسؤوله عن
التحقيق في الاحداث الحاليه في السودان
الى ذلك مشاهدينا اكدت المتحدثه باسم
البيت الابيض كارينجيم انه لا يوجد لدى
اداره امريكيه اي خطط لعمليات اجلاء من
السودان وسط تواصل اطلاق النار بكثافه في
الخرطوم
لا خطط حاليا لعمليات اجلاء من السودان
برعايه امريكيه مع تواصل اطلاق النار في
الخرطوم رغم بدع سريان الهدنه ادعو جميع
الامريكيين في السودان التحسن بمكان امن
نتابع معكم هذه الصور ايضا المباشره
للعربيه من الخرطوم ونشاهد فيها اعمده
الدخان التي
تتصاعد بسبب الاشتباكات الدائره بين قوات
الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش السوداني لليوم
الخامس على التوالي في صبيحه هذا اليوم
مشاهدينا اندلعت حرائق هائله في محيطي
مبنى القياده العامه ومطار الخرطوم صباح
اليوم جراء الاشتباكات بين الطرفين وشهود
عيان ايضا مشاهدينا نتحدث عن استهداف
خزانات وقود داخل المطار الذي تتصاعد منه
الادخنه الكثيفه كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا هذه
الاشتباكات تستمر لمده خمسه ايام على
التوالي رغم موافقه قوات الدعم السريع
وقوات الجيش ايضا على مقترح وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي بعقد هدنه لوقف اطلاق النار لمده
24 ساعه ولكنها لم ترى النور للاسف الشديد
نذكر ايضا
العجل مشاهدينا السفير الروسيه بالخرطوم
يقول ندرس اجلاء موظفين من السفاره لكن من
المستحيل تركوا السودان الان الجيش
السوداني ايضا نشر مقطع مصورا تابعناه قبل
قليل الاصطفاف قواته قبل ما وصفه ببدء
المرحله الثانيه من العمليات
مشاهدينا من القاهره تنضم الينا السيده
اسماء الحسين مديره تحرير صحيفه الاهرام
والمختصه في الشؤون الافريقي اهلا بك سيدي
اسماء معنا في هذه التغطيه بدايه هل
تعتقدين ان غياب عامل الثقه هو السبب
الرئيسي في فشل هذه الهدنه اما ان هناك
اخرى
نعم اهلا وسهلا
بالطبع يعني هناك اسباب عديده ادت الى
الوضع الماسي امامنا والذي يعني هو وضع
ماساوي بكل معنى الكلمه
بالفعل ازمه عدم الثقه
اشتدت اللي هو بين الطرفين في الفتره
الماضيه وكلنا راينا التراشق الذي تم
بالبين الطرفين على خلفيه امور عديده من
بينها تحالفات المتباينه لكل طرف السيد
حميد اصبح اقرب الى قاده قوى الحريه
وتغيير المجلس المركزي والسيد البرهان
اصبح اقرب الى الكتله الديمقراطيه وحلفائه
من فنون النظام السابق ذهب الامر
بالسيد حميدتي الى وصف ما قام به السيد
البرهان في 25 من اكتوبر في عام 2021 بانه
انقلاب وانه لم يوصل الى شيء و لم يكن
راضيا عنه بالتالي كانت هناك تراشات عديده
وازمه ثقه عنيفه
وفاقمتها اطراف لعبت على هذه
التباينات بين الطرفين بالاضافه طبعا الى
مصالح المطامح الشخصيه طموحات الشخصيه لكل
طرف
وامور عديده اخرى طيب فشل هذه الهدنه سيد
اسماء يعني هل سيغضب واشنطن التي عفوا
التي جاءت هذه الهده طبعا بترتيبات
واقتراح من وزير خارجيتها هل تعتقدين ان
ذلك سيدفع واشنطن لاتباعي نهج مختلف في
التعاطي مع الطرفين اقصد طبعا الدعم
السريع والقوات المسلحه السودانيه
نعم اعتقد انه الولايات المتحده بذلت خلال
الايام الماضيه جهود كبيره بالتنسيق مع
حلفائها في المنطقه من اجل الوصول الى هذه
الهدنه واعتقد انه سيكون هناك
تصعيد في خطوات واجراءات واشنطن تجاه
الطرفين وكلنا بدانا نرى اللهجه المتشدده
من قبل مشرعين في الكونجرس الامريكي هددوا
بضروره لوحوا بضروره فرض عقوبات فرديه على
قاده العسكريين من الجانبين وهذا يعني ان
واشنطن ستصعد في اجراءاتها
وستتخذ ايضا يعني خطوات مع حلفائها في
المنطقه وفي العالم من اجل ممارسه اقصى
درجات الضغط على هؤلاء المدنيين الذين
الان يضربون الحائط بكل الاعراف والقوانين
الدوليه ويعتدون على
الوفود الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه والاوروبيه
وعلى العاملين في
المنظمات الانسانيه فضلا عن اتخزهم الشعب
السوداني يعني
رهينه في هذه الحرب وهو عالق في البيوت
وفي المدن وفي العاصمه دون ان افق واضح
للخروج من هذا المازق يعني فيما يتعلق
بالعقوبات التي اشرت اليها يعني هل يبدو
ان قاده الطرفين
كثيرا لهذه العقوبات التي قد ينظر اليها
البعض على انها فزاعه فقط يعني في غيابي
تاثير يذكر لهذه العقوبات على دول وكيانات
اخرى حول العالم
نعم هناك مسؤوليه كبيره الان على القوه
الدوليه وايضا على القوى في الاقليم سواء
كانت هذه القوه عربيه دول عربيه او دول
افريقيه على الجامعه العربيه ايضا على
منظمه الاتحاد الافريقي الوضع خطير للغايه
ولا يمكن ان يترك يعني السودان الكبير
البلد العربي الافريقي الكبير
رهينه لهذين الطرفين المتحاربين
ونترك نزيف الدم بهذا شكل البعثات
الدبلوماسيه محتجزه المنظمات الانسانيه
عاجزه عن الحركه الوضع ماساوي بكل معنى
الكلمه وما يظهر على سطح اعتقد انه جزء
ضئيل من الصوره الكامله التي يعني هي
ممتده بطول السودان وعرضه وبالتالي هذه
المسؤوليه الدوليه عن هذا الامر وهذه
الماساه التي تحدث في السودان من المؤكد
انها ستدفع اطراف عديده في المجتمع الدولي
والاقليم من اجل التحرك
لوضع حد لهذا التصعيد المتبادل
والاتحركات اود ان اسالك عن القاهره يعني
الاهميه التي تكتسبها السودان بالنسبه
لمصر معروفه كونه يمثل عمقا استراتيجيا
مهما وكبيرا ايضا لمصر ما بدا القلق في
القاهره ازاء ما يحدث في السودان
هو قلق شديد للغايه قلق على كل المستويات
والان هناك يعني عمل
على اكثر من صعيد في القاهره من اجل حل
هذه الازمه هناك ازمه بالطبع المصريين
العسكريين الذين كانوا موجودين في مروي
ومحاولات لحل هذه الازمه هناك المصريين
العالقين من الطلاب والمواطنين المصريين
الموجودين في الخرطوم ولا يمكن ايضا ان
يتم اخراجهم والمطارات مغلقه والحدود هناك
قلق كبير بشان السودان كله بشان مواطنيه
بشان هؤلاء الضحايا الذين يسقطون بشان
يعني وضع السودان ومستقبله الذي اصبح الان
يعني على حافه الهاويه او هو متجه الى
الهاويه بسرعه كبيره ويجب ان يتم وقف هذا
التردي في الاحوال جميعا التي سيكون لها
انعكاسات ضخمه جدا على مصر في المقام
الاول على كل دول جوار السودان على منطقه
البحر الاحمر والقرن الافريقي القرن
الافريقيه على السلم والامن في العالم كله
لانه السودان يعني بلد مفتوح على جيران
عديدين مساحات طويله حدود لا يمكن ان تحمى
بالسلاح ما لم يكن هناك امن واستقرار في
هذا البلد ولن يتحقق ذلك الا عبر وقف هذه
الحرب اللعينه ومن ثم التوجه الى حل يفضي
الى يعني دعم تطلعات الشعب السوداني في
تحول مدني ديمقراطي حقيقي يمكن ان يكون
مخرج لكل مشكلاته التاريخيه كيف يمكن ان
تتحرك القاهره اذا هذا الملف يعني هل
ستعتمد القاهره على علاقات حسن الجوار
للتعاطي مع الطرفين ام انها في تقديرك
تمتلك كره ضغط يمكن ان ترغمهما بها على
الاستجابه للتهدئه ونزع فتيل هذه الازمه
نعم القاهره لديها دافعيه للتحرك لديها
مصالح ستتضرر واكبر ما يمكن ان يتضرر ان
يترك السودان هكذا في حال في هذا الوضع
الهش الضعيف الذي يمكن ان ينهار في اي
لحظه مصر انفتحت منذ اللحظه الاولى للازمه
على مسارات عديده هناك اتصالات دوليه
عديده بالامم المتحده بالاتحاد الافريقي
دعت لعقد الجامعه العربيه بالتنسيق مع دول
عربيه عديده وهي الان تحاول ان تطرح ما
يمكن ان
يسمى اتصالا بين الطرفين المتحاربين قالت
انها تقف على مسافه واحده من الطرفين
وانها مستعده للوساطه واعتقد
هذا الجهد المصري يجب ان يكون مدعوم باكبر
قدر من الدعم الدولي والاقليمي يمكن ان
يتم ممرات ممكن
يعني كما طرحت مراقبين من اجل مراقبه
الهدنه لكن كل ذلك لن يتحقق الا بضغوط
مكثفه للغايه من قبل الاطراف الدوليه
والاقليميه المؤثره على الطرفين
المتقاتلين من اجل التهدئه وقبل والهدنه
قبل الوصول الى الهدنه وفتح هذه الممرات
التي ترغب فيها القاهره وايضا لجان
المراقبه والتحقيق وغيرها طيب ضيفي قبل
قليل الاستاذ المغربي الكاتب الصحفي
المحايله ان ما يحدث الان من صراع في
السودان هو ليس صراعا سوداني سودانيه كما
يبدو وانه انعكاس لتقاطع دعينا نقول مصالح
قوى دوليه متنافسه على ترسيخ نفوذها في
هذا البلد وما يكتسبه ايضا من اهميه
جيستراتيجيه كبيره هل تتفقين مع هذا الطرح
نعم يعني
بالفعل يعني لم يكن الى حد كبير
يصل الى هذا المشهد
الدموي الاحتراضي بين الطرفين الا اذا
كانت هناك اطراف ومصالح دوليه متقاطعه في
السودان بعضها يدعم هذا الطرف وبعضها يدعم
الطرف الاخر لم نكن نصل الى هذا المشهد
لولا ان هناك اطرافا في الداخل السوداني
وفي الخارج ايضا العالمي والاقليمي اعطت
ضوءا ما اخدرا بانها يمكن ان تقف الى جانب
هذه القوه او تلك وبالتالي فان هذه
التقاطعات لن تنعكس على وضع السودان وحده
وانما على ايضا مصالح هذه القوه الدوليه
جميعا التي ستتضرر اكبر ضرر اذا ما استمر
هذا الصراع واذا مات وسع
وامتد الى انحاء السودان وربما جر اليه اط
الاقليميه اخرى او دوليه وبالتالي الوضع
خطير جدا
والحل في السودان الحل السلمي التفاوضي هو
افضل طريق ووقف العنف الجاري الان يجب ان
يكون اولويه لكل القوه الدوليه والاقليميه
معاق باهل الدول الاقليميه والدوليه هل
هناك فرصه لتوحيد جهود هذه الدول تحتوي
ظله واحده
لتقرير وجهات النظر ربما ولي نزفته الازمه
في السودان ايضا
حتى الان كلنا نرى البيانات الصادره عن
القوه الدوليه جميعا الصين وروسيا وامريكا
واوروبا
الامارات ومصر والسعوديه واثيوبيا الاتحاد
الافريقي والجامعه العربيه كلهم يؤكدون
على ضروره وقف العنف وضروره الحل عبر
الحوار واعتقد انه هناك حاجه لتوحيد هذه
الجهود
ووضع حد
للتردي الحاصل الان في السودان الذي سيكون
له عواقب وخيمه على جميع الاطراف شكرا
جزيل الشكر لك من القاهره كنت مع السيده
اسماء الحسيني مديره تحرير صحيفه الاهرام
والمختصه في الافريقيه تحيه سيدي اسماء
[موسيقى]
العربات الدعم السريع
مطر بدون برك هنا مطرنا بدون سحاب
سلاح النقلي
الفرقه الرابعه اسود النيل الازرق
مطر بدون براك كويس مطر بدون سحاب عدل
ولسه
اجداد بنجيب شاي
وعرض لكم
انتهى اتفكت منكم
الفرقه هناك
كان زمان
السميري بس
[موسيقى]
القوات المسلحه
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
رباعي
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
ومخزن متكامل بكل المعدات
الموظف الله اكبر الله اكبر لذلك تعلن
زياده الفرقه 18 مشابه ان ولايه النيل
الابيض
استلام كل
ول والمتمردين
كل المواقع التي استلمتها 2018
[تصفيق]
من شهدائنا الكرام وخالص التعادل الاسري
في سياق الوضع الصحي الصعب في السودان
دانت منظمه الصحه العالميه بشده الهجمات
التي تعرض لها الموظفون الصحيون والمرافق
الصحيه وسيارات الاسعاف وقالت المنظمه في
بيان ان هذه الهجمات اخره في الازدياد
وتسببت بمقتل ثلاثه اشخاص على الاقل
واصابه اثنين اخرين كما اشارت المنظمه الى
ان هذه الهجمات تحد من امكانيه حصول
المواطنين على الرعايه اللازمه الامر الذي
يعرض مزيدا بل يعرض مزيدا من الارواح
للخطر وعباره منظمه الصحه العالميه
مشاهدينا عن قلقها اثر التقارير التي
تحدثت عن ضرب المرافق الصحيه ونهبها ايضا
واختطاف سيارات الاسعاف
ولفتت منظمه الصحه الى ان الهجمات على
العاملين والمنشات الصحيه انتهاك النقص
للقانون الدولي مطالبه جميع الاطراف بضمان
الوصول الامن للمرضى والعاملين الى
المستشفيات بدورها دعت وزاره الصحه
السودانيه لايقاف العمليات المسلحه التي
طالت المرافق الصحيه في ولايه الخرطوم
وادت الى خروج 16 مستشفى على الخدمه فضلا
عن صعوبه وصول الكوادر الصحيه والاطباء
الى المستشفيات
وكذلك عدم تمكن سيارات الاسعاف من اداء
مهامها واشار وزير الصحه هيثم ابراهيم الى
ان القطاع الصحي سيعاني من اثار كارثيه
اضافيه مع اطاله امد الصراع
مشاهدينا وهذه المشاهد جويه الخرطوم مع
استمرار الاشتباكات وتصاعد اعمده الدخان
كما نتابع في هذه الصور تتصاعد اذا
الاعمده الدخان بسبب الاشتباكات الدائره
بين القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الجيش
قوات الدعم السريع عند دلعت ايضا مشاهدينا
حرائق هائله في صبيحه هذا اليوم في محيط
مبنى القياده العامه للجيش ومطار الخرطوم
كما تحدث شهود عيان ايضا عن استهدافي
خزانتي وقود داخل المطار الذي تتصاعد منه
الادخنه الكثيفه كل ذلك مشاهدينا ياتي في
سياق هذه الاشتباكات المستمره لليوم
الخامس على التوالي بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع رغم موافقه الطرفين
على مقترح وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انت على
هدنه لوقف اطلاق النار لمده 40 ساعه
هذا هو ناشد نائب رئيس نقابه الاطباء
السوداني علي بشير في تصريحاته العربيه
ناشد بضروره توفير وممرات امنه لنقل
واخلاء المرضى مؤكدا ان الوضع الطبي اخذ
في الانهيار
حقيقه الوضع
التاريخي
والنظام الصحي الان يمكن علينا ان نقول
انه منار تماما يزيل تعرض عدد من
المستشفيات للقصف المباشر وخروجها عن
الخدمه
واخرها مستشفى فضيل الذي تعرض
بالاسلحه الثقيله مما ادى الى ثقبه في
القائد المركزي وصهاريج المياه الرئيسيه
والمخصصه لمرضى غسيل الكلى كما ان هنالك
عدد كبير من المستشفيات محدد بالخروج عن
الخدمه نتيجه لشح
النقود المطالب الاكثر الحاحا هي الالتزام
بالخدمه والعمل على الوقفه الدائم لاطلاق
النار وقف هذه الحرب العاطفيه
كما نطالب بفتح مسارات امنه وتحديدها
وتامينها من قبل هذه القوات المتقاتله
لا يتسع المكان هنا مستشفيات تكاد تفيض
بالمرضى وان فاضت فلا مستلزمات فيها ربما
ولا حتى اكسجين
مستشفيات تحت القصف قصف بالتوقيت الحرج لم
يتمكن مرضى الكلى من اتمام جلسه غسل طارئه
لكن ما ترى ايضا لم يكن في الحسبان
ملاذ غير امن بعد قصف العديد من
المستشفيات وتوقف بعضها عن الخدمه هذا
مستشفى ابن سينا لا شيء غير النار تعرض
للدمار بعد سقوط قدائف عشوائيه عليه
وهذا مشفى اخر سمي باسم الشعب ولم يسلم من
قضاء في العسكر تدمر بالكامل يعتبر من
اكبر مستشفيات الخرطوم واكثرها حيويه
ثمه مراكز طبيه عده لكنها تعاني من نقص
المستلزمات والكوادر ايضا امر اثار قلقا
دوريا فضلا عن قلق السودانيين راح نشهد
اكيد انقطاع مش بس بمواد الطبيه ولكن عدم
تسيير المرافق العامه راح يكون للاسف
الشيء اللي راح نواجهه
قريبا وهذا الشيء منه ابدا ايجابي بالعكس
لازم نتدخل بسرعه لما تتفاقم الاوضاع اكثر
واكثر دعوات حقوقيه لوقف اطلاق النار لفتح
مسارات امنه لنقل المساعدات الانسانيه
للمدنيين وان تحققت لفتره فثمت تحولات
عسكريه بين حين واخر قد تجعل الحاله اكثر
ضبابيه
غذاء السالم العربيه
الدكتور محمد نعمه الله جبريل الباحث
الاستراتيجيات ودراسات المستقبلي اهلا
بالدكتور محمد معنا في هذه التغطيه بدايه
لماذا لم يحسم الجيش السوداني حتى اللحظه
هذه المواجهات مع الدعم السريع رغم دخول
المواجهات يومها الخامس حتى اليوم
اهلا بك
[موسيقى]
يحسم هذا التمرد
لاسباب عديده ولا انه لم يكن هنالك يعني
توقع
[موسيقى]
مقرات
الدعم السريع لحزبان انها كانت تشغل
وتحرث مناطق استراتيجيه كثيره جدا
ومواقعها هي نفسها مواقع كثيره جدا لذلك
تم اولا التعامل مع هذه المواقع واخراجه
من
التي تحتلها والمواقع الاستراتيجيه التي
تحريسه
واجب اصيل تام بالنسبه لها طيب الدكتور
محمد اسمح لي فقط بدايه
النقطه الاولى التي اشرت اليها والمتعلقه
ان هذا التمرد جاء مفاجئاسه الاممي في
حضرته للامم المتحده قبل يومين تحدثوا
وقال ان الطرفين يعني طبعا الجيش والدعم
السريع بدا في التعبئه قبل اسابيع من هذه
الاشتباكات ما يعني ان ذلك كان متوقع ايضا
بالنسبه للجيش ما رايك
هذا هو الذي هو الذي خطط هو ويعلم
الاستعدادات بتاعه الطرف اخر
الفلتر ده كان هو الجزء الاساسي في في هذا
في هذا النزاع وبدا يتحدث عن اشياء لا
تخصه وخرج عن تفويضه يتحدث عن دعم عشر سنه
وخمسه سنه هذا ليس شانه وانا استمعاته
لتجريره كامل
وبعد هذا البتاع ان يطلب هذا الفقه دعنا
من فرقه ودعنا من الرباعيه ودعنا من
عمليه عسكريه وانت سؤالك لماذا
تسلم بعمليه العسكريه اما اسباب اذا كنت
طيب لكن نحن في العسكريه
المفاه هو المعني بتامين امنه سلامه
السودان والسودانيين
وبدا اول هجوم
بالهجوم على منزل
رئيس مجلس السياده اللي هو جاره يعني يعني
مباشره
الحيطه
وكانت الخطه ان يتم اعتقال
رئيس مجلس القياده حتى هو يستلم اذا هذه
مفاجاه انا افتكر بمساله لانه من داخل
الصندوق زي ما يعني
هذا العمل
[موسيقى]
او مطلوب من
حراسه هذه الوقت محمد النقطه الاولى هي
المفاجاه المفاجاه هل التمرد كما وصفته ما
هي نقطه اخرى لعدم الحسم حتى الان
[موسيقى]
المرحله العامه
في
[موسيقى]
الكوبري شمبان وكل المواقع الرئيسيه التي
يعني هم يتواجدون فيها واكتمل
ذلك
[موسيقى]
هذه المرحله الاولى
المرحله الثانيه
انه في قوات اصلا كان مطلوب منها
التامين المناطق الاستراتيجيه
تفهم هذه القوات موجوده والمطار الدولي
يفتح المطار الحربي والمطار الحربي يقود
الى منزل
المجلس السياده ورئيس مجلس السياده اذا هم
هؤلاء في قلب
الموقع الموقع الاستراتي
هذه المنطقه المساله الثانيه
وانتهى الوقت الدكتور محمد باختصار شديد
هي القوات الدعم السريع المساله الثالثه
اللي هي قصدت
ظهر البعير هذه العمليه اللي هو
الى مروي
اعتبار انه هذا الانقلاب يعني مخطط له انه
يستولوا على رئيس مجلس السياده
ويعلن الحكومه
وحكومه امر واقع ويجيهم دعم خارجي من
ولهذا كان لماذا
نظرك هي الاسباب التي دعت الى عدم حسم
الجيش لهذه المعارك حتى الان اعتذر منك
هذا ما سمح به الوقت من الخرطوم كنت معنا
اللواء الركن الدكتور محمد نعمه الله
جبريل الباحث الاستراتيجيات المستقبليه
تحياتي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تفرض المعارك القائمه بين قوات الدعم
السريع والقوات المسلحه عده سيناريوهات
على مستقبل السودان منها سيناريوهات قادمه
انفجار هائل وسط الخرطوم دخان اسود كثيف
يصنع مشهدا قاتما للسودان احتمالاته هي ان
يفوز البرهان في المعركه وتنشق جماعه
حميتي ان يفوز حميدتي ويتبعثر الجيش وتدخل
البلاد حربا اهليه نزاع يستمر لسنوات طوال
بين لا غالب ولا مغلوب يصطلح الطرفان
ويقتسمان الصلاحيات وهو سيناريو الذي
يتمناه السوداني
قد تحسم المعركه العسكريا في بعض المناطق
في السودان لكن الصراع قد يطول بسبب
التقسيمات القبليه والسياسيه لكلا الطرفين
المتنازعين هذا معناه اننا امام مرحله من
الصراع الطويل الامد للاسف الشديد سوف
تستمر الامور هي على هذا النحو فتره اطول
مما هو يعني يبدو السيناريو الذي يرجوه
السودانيون هو المصالحه يلتقي حميدتي
والبرهان ويتفقان على دمج قوه الدعم
السريع مع القوات المسلحه ليكون للسودان
جيش واحد يحفظ الامن ويلبي امنيات هذا
الطفل الصغير
الجيش السوداني تنفيذي عمليه لاجلاء طلاب
العالقين منذ اربعه ايام في كليه الهندسه
بجامعه الخرطوم وقال الجيش في بيان ان
قواته اتخذت الحيطه والحذر حفاظا على
سلامتهم حتى اجلائهم بالكامل بخروج امن
واحد واحد
[موسيقى]
على مدى السنوات الماضيه افدته رصاصه خرجت
منذ خمسه ايام من قلب العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم لتتحول بعدها البلاد الى ساحه حرب
يديرها من كان يعد بحمايتها وحليف امس بات
عدو اليوم
جبهه حرب جديده فتحت افواه السلاح في
السودان طرفها الحرب عسكريان كلاهما تمرس
في ميادين القتال بدارفورد اما وصفه السلع
فمكوناتها تقتصر على وجود قوتين مسلحتين
داخل الدوله الواحده
مصير البلاد حاليا بات على راحتي من كان
من المفترض حمايته والقادم لا ينذر الا
بصيف حار سيثقل كاهل السودانيين مجددا بعد
ان عاشوا حروبا وانقلابات عده جلبت
الويلات لهم
تاريخيا المره الاخيره التي تقاتل فيها
قائد عسكري ونائبه شرقي افريقيا كان في
جنوب السودان وقتل حينها حوالي 400 الف
شخص اما صراع اليوم فيزعزع استقرار جارتها
الشماليه وما يدور حاليا فيه قد ينتهي فقط
بفوز احدهم في المعركه مع عدم استبعاد حرب
اهليه طويله الامد قد تجر جيرانها وفق
صحيفه
على مدى السنوات الماضيه تشارك البرهان
واحمدت معارك عده معا يد واحده وقوه
مشتركه
ففي عام 2021 اكد احمدتي لصحيفه فينانشل
تاينس ان قوات الدعم السريع تدعم القوات
المسلحه السودانيه فيما اخبر البرهان
الصحيفه الغربيه انه بمجرد اكمال الانتقال
الى الديمقراطيه سيعود القاده الى الذكنات
وسيتم اجراء تصويت في عام 2023
وعود تبخرت مع اطلاق رصاصه الاولى منذ
اربعه ايام من العاصمه الخرطوم ليدخل
السودان ازمه خطيره ربما يمكن ان تحسم
صلحا او تتوسع وتاكل ما تبقى من البلاد
اياد حمود العربيه
اذا طلعت قناه العربيه اراء الجاليه
السودانيه المقيمه في الاردن بخصوص الوضع
الامني غير المستقر الذي تشهده بلادهم
الحرب يعني وصل للخرطوم للعاصمه فمش
قادرين نتواصل مع اهالينا وفي ناس كمان من
هناك بدهم يطلعوا ويجوا وفي ناس من هون
بدهم يروحوا يعيدوا مثل ما اهاليهم ما في
مجال حاليا المطار مسكر الوضع صعب النت
مسكر يعني حتى احنا طريقه التواصل
بالانترنت مش عارفين نتواصل معها دينا احد
الذين عانوا من الحروب يعني ما جئت الى
الاردن الا بسبب الحرب وهذه الحرب انا
اعتبرها فتنه وانما يحدث ويدور الان في
السودان هو عباره عن فتنه وهذه كلها نتيجه
تراكمات سياسيه خاطئه وبالتالي الان
المتضرر الاول هو المواطن
والله بشوف الاوضاع في السودان كثير صعبه
والوضع كثير خطر على الناس الشعب وربنا
يحمي الوطن ويحمي الشعب وكثير بالنسبه
للطيران عنا بالاردن كثير صعب محتاجين
اشياء من السودان ما قادرين ومحتاجين نبعث
لهم ما قادرين نبعث لازم الدوله السودانيه
دوله تكون مدنيه حره ديمقراطيه دوله
برلمانيه ذات سياده وطنيه يعني ده اما
التشبث والعمليات بتاعت الانقلاب او
التجارب بتاعه التجارب بتاعت الدول
السابقه فبيشوف انه يعني هناك شعب
السوداني في الشارع يعني ما بنقبل حتى ولو
يعني
العسكر استلم او سيطر او الدعم السريع
سيطر فكلاهم كل العمرين مر يعني ما في اشي
يعني ما ضافوا اشي جديد سوى الحرب الاسيح
حاليا بتكون موجوده
جراء الاشتباكات المستمره بين القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع سقط
الكثير من الضحايا المدنيين من بينهم
الطبيب الشابه ابنه كابتن هلال ومدربه
السابق فوزي المرضي بينما اصيبت والدتها
وذلك جراء مقذوف ناري طائش اصاب نافذه
منزلهم في ام درمان
حقيقه
في المستشفى في الحاره
طلبت مني
اخوها بالعربيه طالعه بمصر الاحياء
وصلت البيت مبسوطه جدا مرتاحه في الوضع
بتاعتي
جدا لما طلعت من الاوضه للصاله
بتاعه الشباك
مختلفه القزاز
هو ما فتحت القزازه كل بيت قالت ورا امها
كسره القزاز ضربت امها في الاول في الفقه
الايمن حقها شعره اللحم بتاع ضرباتها في
ومشط ضربت البيت في قلبها
مباشره وقعت
متوفيه توفى الطوال في الحال
ة مشاهدينا الزميل راوي العالمي تصحبكم
على راس الساعه متابعه طيبه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات